so let's get to uh you you obviously
build this platform yeah
um was on the radar uh
uh something that you had always kind of
like
because I I think early on I was seeing
you were doing stuff during the pandemic
on like Zoom yep and which everybody was
doing right we all had to do that um
when did you initially did you launch on
the radar during the pandemic or was it
prior to the pandemic like give me the
the kind of the history well like on the
radar started in in 2018 so like I
originally had the idea because for me
like you know I'm 26 so I'll 2018 I was
like I was like 21 22-ish and my biggest
thing for me back then was like I you
know I was a young kid and and I was
listening to like you know the little
Uzi versus yachties and and the whatnot
and I would see them go on different
platforms and I just felt like they
weren't really understood by you know
you think about like the infamous Joe
Budden moment with him and yachty and
it's like even like the Ebro one where
they were like trying to give him a rap
over some Primo [__] right and I don't
necessarily blame them for those moments
you know what I'm saying because you
know they just didn't understand their
generation right you know what I'm
saying they're younger kids right so I
felt like at that time I was like damn
like I don't really see them I'm being
represented properly in a media space
and I didn't really see anybody
um in my age really being able to be in
this media space and also kind of be
that kind of that like that person
that's able to grab them and help them
you know be presented properly the way
that like you know you think of like an
Angie Martinez in the 90s wait
um with everybody from New York right or
you think of uh or bless you or you
think of um who am I thinking of um
Columbia radio station I don't know why
I'm blanking right now she's in my
stretching button yeah stretching babito
right like or how stretching babito was
there to help bring up biggie uh Wu-Tang
they had like some of their first three
songs
you think about those and like I wanted
to do something like that for this
generation so I came up with the idea
um back in in like December of 2018
right after I graduated college you know
I kind of were you already at Power yeah
I was already full-time on on um on the
digital side of things I was part of the
Angie Martinez show I helped out with
Breakfast Club so I did a little bit of
everything and and when it came to like
creating this space I was like you know
I wanted it to be like on the radio
station but they were like you know it's
build it on your own you know what I'm
saying like kind of started getting
going they had a room there that I could
use it was the same room that
Charlemagne used to film brilliant
idiots in so I was just filming like one
interview a day right or like one
interview a week something like that and
it was just I was Finding anybody and
anybody and everybody I can interview
just trying to start building my
connection so I was doing that for a
while and then I started making more
younger friends in the industry
um and that's how I ended up getting up
some bigger artists are getting a little
more recognition in New York and then
the pandemic came and like right before
the pandemic I did this interview with
uh bankroll Freddie and like that was
kind of like my biggest interview at the
time I had like I think I had like 20
000 views like in like a week or
whatever which was like a lot for me at
the time right and I was like okay cool
I have all this traction but now like
everything is shutting down dead right
so I was like in a space where it was
weird because I also had another show at
the time I did with power called uh
enter player two which was like a video
game show so I'll play uh like Mortal
Kombat 2K with like some artist like I
had Chef G and Sleepy Hollow on that
show too which was like one of their
most talkative interviews which was
really dope at the time right so
pandemic came I'm like and I was like
damn what do I do now like I really
don't know what to do
um the zoom interviews came around and
then like I kind of got out of this like
you know depressive state that I was in
not knowing where to go in my show just
having to do the Social Media stuff
every single day which was like it was
fine but it's like it's not what I love
to do right
um and I just started doing like two to
three Zoom interviews like every day
like I was just like you know what
anybody again anybody and everybody who
I can connect with in any place in the
world I'm gonna do I'm gonna figure it
out so I was doing interviews with um
with people like some afrobeat artists
like I did Stone boy very early on
um in my career and then I was doing
like people from like the Carolinas
Florida like literally anybody that I
could do a zoom interview with
um and then it kind of came to a point
where it was like we had I figured out
this rhythm with the content I'm like
okay I think I know what I'm doing now
and we started you know getting out of
the pandemic and I was like you know I
want to do live interviews so I started
doing those again and and I came up with
I had always had this idea for
freestyles on the show and I had done
them kind of ghetto before like I would
have my laptop literally sitting right
here plug the headphones into the laptop
and then I would put the volume all the
way up let them wrap and then in
post-production I would try to hear
where the beat started and I'll try to
match it up that's [__] crazy super
super ghetto right but it worked it
worked it worked I only had like one or
two that I couldn't put out because of
that so we had that done and then I
found this spot well because you guys
had freestyles where they weren't
wearing headphones sometimes right am I
tripping no we always have okay maybe
I'm tripping I just saw somebody
freestyling there was no headphones on
and I was like no somebody somebody [__]
there was I was like what is going on
here they don't have headphones on where
they hearing the beat like actually okay
there was one there was one um we do we
had like some ciphers like we did a
Christmas Cipher we called it the uh
Christmas and Harlem Cipher I remember
seeing that you guys had like a [__]
78 people around yeah yeah we had like
16 people rapping that that was that was
a really dope moment too but that that
we had like a speaker outside
um and they could hear it same with the
ladies night that we just did in Atlanta
we that one had a we had a uh an
external speaker that they could hear
the beat played off of it's gonna have
he would just handle the yeah my
producer Rob is like a magician with
that I don't even know how he does it
but he he finesses it but we started
doing the freestyles
um like kind of shortly after like I
kind of caught the wave of the drill
scene like I had caught you know k-flog
be love and Dougie B I did their first
interview together
um I did Dusty Locane busy banks around
that time and then I was like all right
I got this motion doing these interviews
what else Bobby Fischer guys yeah Bobby
shout out Bobby man shout out Bobby bro
um but yeah so then like I found this
spot called hmd Studios out in uh
Brooklyn which is you know sadly closing
its doors really soon
um but that's kind of where we started
doing the freestyles and I just like I
have my producer Rob who I mentioned at
the time and I'm like bro we're doing
all these interviews with like these
Dope Up And Coming artists I'm like can
we do freestyles here and he called over
the owners to the studio and who are
also friends of mine he's like is this
possible and they're like yeah this is
possible so we started off just kind of
like doing again once again like anybody
who wanted to come rap
just bring them to come wrap pull up and
one of the first people who I had come
wrap on my on the freestyles and that
studio was Lola Brook because me and
Lola had done interviews before so we
had this relationship and then kind of
from there we just kind of caught this
wave we caught the drill wave in New
York and then I mean yeah freestyle yeah
I spices [__] was not sure if you'll
ever do another one of those ever again
hey man look if I have the only ice
spice free if I have the only ice spice
freestyle ever I'll be happy I'll be
happy but like you know we caught a lot
of really dope incredible artists early
on and I feel like you know that's kind
of where I wanted to be at in 2018.
um I it took it took a bit of time but
like you know I feel like a lot of young
people in this industry don't always
realize how long things take and then
you guys
so when we started doing freestyles for
the podcast we kind of started the same
way I think because we were thinking of
the monetization route so I would have
my producer Tony chock just give me a
beat yeah that was original that
wouldn't get flagged so a lot of your
guys's beats are from producers that
let's not like
they're freestyling over like pound town
you know what I'm saying like yeah his
original instrument instrumentals right
some cases yeah I mean you know I kind
of like to give the artists a free range
to do what they what they want
um we do have a lot of we have in-house
producers now uh my boy Fritz Cooks up a
lot of the beets um Hitman gave us the
beat for the ladies night Cypher so that
was really dope but I try to give them
the free range you know um I got a great
partnership with create on the
monetization side of things so they
helped me kind of sort through all those
things with the beats and kind of like
getting copyrights on
um are you guys putting all the
freestyles on like Spotify and all that
[__] not all of them but we have a lot
like we put out
um like what 115 already this year
115 already this year so we have like
entire we have a pretty big catalog that
we just dropped this year Alone
um but we try to encourage artists now
especially the up-and-coming ones it's
like look if you coming on the show you
might as well do an original beat so we
can put you in our ecosystem on
streaming and then you get the on the
radar fans we get your fans and then we
kind of are able to marry that together